now the government has insisted
throughout the coronavirus crisis that
it's been guided by the science we've
seen the experts standing alongside the
prime minister at those daily press
conferences of course - and some are
true report was the government's chief
scientific adviser for four and a half
years he joins us now from West London
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning now I know that
you've been really following and
involved in the development of that
vaccine for covert 19 and when
realistically do you think a vaccine
could be ready well I'd like to start by
picking up the point that Tony Blair has
just made which in fact is that there is
enormous international scientific Co
working on this and so SETI which is the
Coalition for epidemic preparedness
innovation which the UK has just
committed 210 million pounds to has been
working across the world on vaccine
development they have eight in their
active pipeline at the moment one of
which is one that UK research and
innovation and others have been funding
in Oxford and so there is an enormous
amount going on and he's absolutely
right also that science and technology
and innovation is critical to both
providing the advice and the management
as I told you when I bit recently the
reality is that we need to be sure that
a vaccine is effective and doesn't have
side effects or serious side effects so
it will take probably a year to 18
months everyone will work extremely hard
to make it as quick as they possibly can
the regulators are working much faster
than they do normally and so everyone
will do absolutely everything they can
to get it to people as quickly as
possible
and indeed the scale-up of the that
particular oxford vaccine although you
know whether it stands a better chance
than any of the others who knows will
will bear to manufacture up to a million
doses fairly quickly but it's a long way
from protecting the whole population and
as I say the the the other thing we need
to understand is more about the
protective immune response to
coronavirus Tony Blair was also saying
that he thinks the most likely way out
of the lockdown if you like is actually
through mass testing nearly everyone he
said could be tested
and then to find out more as you say
about that immune response and do you
think that that perhaps is the most
realistic way out of the situation we're
in now
well the science advice is actually
absolutely rock-solid worldwide that the
best way out of this is to keep people
apart from each other which is why the
advice of stay at home is so critically
important in other words one thing we
know is that you need to reduce the
number of people that one infected
person affects on in fact on average
which is about 3/4 as far as we think
down to below one and the only way you
do that is by separating people now it
is also absolutely the case that we need
to be able to test people who are
working in the frontline for whether
they have virus infection and if we're
really going to understand and be able
to model the academic properly we need
to know what fraction of the population
has been infected and so really there
are two types of tests there's the test
for the virus and then there's the tests
for whether people have been infected
and have as has been said already on the
program what should be a protective
immune response for at least once if not
a small number of years just to pick up
on that point and an Oxford University
study this week suggested that up to
half of us could actually have been
infected with corona virus do you think
that's at all realistic that paper has
been first it hasn't actually been
peer-reviewed by other scientists and
secondly it has been pretty uniformly
criticized for it the assumptions that's
make in the modeling firstly it assumed
that there were a limited number of
vulnerable people who would succumb and
the evidence is that although there are
the most vulnerable we know we also know
that some people died of this for
reasons we don't yet fully understand in
terms of their susceptibility and
secondly the model basically put in the
fact that there may be large numbers of
uninfected people the evidence such as
we have it emerging from it the example
is that unfortunately there probably
aren't an enormous number of people
who've been infected but completely
asymptomatic okay and now you were
saying there that the evidence shows
that social distancing keeping apart
from each other is the
your most important thing that we can do
but of course that pays the you know
heavy price you pay for that keeping
away from my loved ones it's a difficult
thing for many people to do and
particularly of course if you're in a
small apartment or something like that
as well and now I just wonder if you
have any stay on how long you think that
the lockdown could go on for because if
that's the most effective thing we can
do and the vaccine that's not gonna be
ready for at least probably a year it
feels as if this could go on for many
months yet yes and that is why the best
advice is coming from the modeling
community and Neil Ferguson himself
who's leading the team at Imperial but
it's also important to mention we're not
dependent on a single team of modelers
there are modelers at the London School
of Hygiene and Tropical Medicine there
are other modelers so they're working
with each other and I can tell you
they're not suffering from groupthink
because these are a very feisty lot of
researchers who you know will argue
right down to them their last details
but what Neil Ferguson is saying is
until at least the end of May and
possibly - but of course that's the
operational challenge because as you say
there's the balance between keeping
society going as normally as it possibly
can making sure that all the supply
lines work minimising that disruption
which of course has potential for
adverse mental health consequences that
we know about from isolation so it's
always that balance between clamping
down on your disease spread whilst at
the same time keeping society going as
normally as we possibly can in an
extraordinary abnormal time and that's
why this real-time modelling this
real-time input into the politicians who
are leading the response by researchers
on the scientific advice group and
emergency reporting - Patra valance and
Chris witty
that's an embedded mechanism that we
have in the UK and I think it is really
among the very best in the world do you
think we can see a situation where we
effectively alternate between periods of
stricter look down relaxing things
slightly and
up a bit more well so I think that is a
possibility and of course everyone is
looking very carefully at a China and
Korea China was obviously sadly ahead of
everyone else in this in terms of the
timing of the epidemic it's the disease
emerged in Wuhan and they've clamped
down very hard and I think everyone
around the world who understands the
epidemiology is looking to see whether
the outbreak does start again because
there's no doubt that cases will have
gone right across the whole of China so
there may be very low levels infection
and again it's that balance between a
stop start stop start and trying to
smooth out the epidemic but having also
I think in the next phase it will be
really important at a time when we have
much better and more abundant testing to
do that testing whenever an outbreak
seems to flare up again and countries
around the world are cooling themselves
up to be able to do that okay thank you
very much for being on the program thank
you very much thank you